[Musique]
gallo page vous avez un énorme pouvoir
médiatique le défaire et faire des
carrières comment vous gérer cette
pression non le pouvoir il faut en user
faut pas en abuser
pierre bourgault qui était mon
professeur en communication médias
oublient jamais que les tribunes que
tueur est un privilège et compléter la
retire et on me le retirer quelquefois
pas très longtemps quand je fais c'est
dénier aux riches très conscient de sow
a fait la vraie question jacuzzi avec l'
influence l'argent comment faites vous
pour garder les deux pieds sur terre la
pauvreté vidal moi j'ai des tombées de
cossette porte et qu'on peut aussi
appeler la garde rapprochée qui est très
rapidement me ramène son temps puis dans
un groupe quand j'étais derrière bo par
la france est devenue populaire vite
leur beyrouth se dit pas vite mais d'un
coup mon et un groupe idec années 20 que
qui prenait un petit peu trop d'angle la
tangente à monter dans un tout où il se
faisait ramener tout de suite taxis
nantais jeunesse a été ramenée ccb rare
que tu que tu deviens que tu quittes le
sol à cinq ans fait parler d'argent pour
moi je commence à avoir de
c'est un moment dans ma vie où j'avais
vécu toute ma vie c'est en avoir quand
les gens me disent pourquoi t'as pas de
bateau mais parce que ça m'intéresse pas
[Musique]
est-ce que des fois vous vous ennuyez de
la veste jaune dorée cube aux rues qui
dans votre plaque en tout cas là on la
ressent régulièrement on va faire le bye
bye entente on avons une tournette
numéro la semaine passée si ab où il
n'existait pas je serais pas ici en
quelque part vers une fête personne
d'entre nous seraient probablement à ce
milieu entre coop à ce niveau là on doit
tous armés au je sais que tu veux
conduire les moeurs survenue sur un golf
et c'est un méga succès ici à l'étranger
en 2008 le couple a évolué depuis un
gong filles 1
guy sylvie serait aujourd'hui ben je
sais pas où ils seraient mais
radio-canada a racheté pour la quatrième
fois le classique et je me fait
regretter encore sur la grille et je me
fait écrire sur les réseaux sociaux à
part votre look pris le téléphone sont
trop grosses c'est mon couple est comme
ça ma blonde née comme ça mon chat mais
comme ça je pense que le le coc
hommes-femmes
j'en avais a pas évolué et en dessous
[Musique]
ça va faire un beau projet actuel qui
vous tient vraiment à coeur c'est
béatrice esprit et votre fil bluetooth
et tout le monde qu'il connaît dit que
guy a lepage montre souvent des photos
de ses enfants sur son téléphone souvent
travail on en fait une voiture
moi j'ai tendance à sacré du jeûne
d'hochelaga maisonneuve puis j'ai jeté
ma marque faciliter un jour mon petit
garçon il ya quatre ans il échappe sa
banane vite l'oeil hagard dans son oeil
a prédit un tabac na waie ce que prix ce
qui sonne moins lui pense que quand
échappe quelque chose
faut que tu dises tabane à la cud fait
ok c'est cette fin comme un bon alors il
faudrait que j'arrête de dit habana
quand j'ai chaque des trous puis surtout
quelqu'un lui fait c'est qu'un grand
sourire c'est totalement déconcertant
même pas drôle
en terminant que la page il ya trois il
ya la page
le premier l'air bo le deuxième un gars
une fille l'animation
le troisième ligne alapage de tout le
monde en parle quel sera le quatrième
violetta ne garde pas greffard que je le
sais pas j'ai 58 ans puis je fais un
métier qui peut arrêter à tout moment
comme il peut continuer jusqu'à 85
chose certaine ça fait des années que je
travaille uniquement parce que j'en ai
envie
sans obligation alors quand j'en aurai
pas en vue plus envie ou que j'avais
l'impression que je prends la place de
quelqu'un
ce qui me préoccupe déjà d'ailleurs ça
m'arrive souvent de refuser d engagement
de participer à des émissions et je fais
ça depuis très très très très longtemps
via la page merci beaucoup merci mon
année 2010 moyens à vous aussi